okay November is COPD awareness month
and Intermountain Healthcare the
sponsors of this next segment are here
to tell us more about this preventable
disease joining us now is Dr Suresh Tani
from Intermountain Healthcare welcome to
the show thank you thank you what is
COPD so COPD stands for chronic
obstructive permit disease COPD is a
very common respiratory condition which
is preventable as well as treatable and
is there's a destruction of the Airways
as well as the what we call alveoliodan
air sacs you know in the lung you know
how many many people currently suffer
from COPD so in the United States there
are about
26.8 million people wow okay but out of
which only 14.8 million have been
diagnosed with a COPD so we still have
12 million people who have been
undiagnosed so okay then what are the
symptoms of COPD the symptoms are the
most common symptom is the cough which
could be with the mucus or the spoodle
production the person can also have a
shortness of breath particularly on the
physical activity okay they may complain
of a chest tightness maybe a complete of
wheezing tiredness fatigue so those are
the main symptoms of the COPD okay those
are the the symptoms so what is causing
it though someone's living a healthy
lifestyle or someone is a smoker what's
what's bringing on COPD so 80 percent of
patients in USA who have COPD they have
a history of smoking cigarettes about
nine percent of patients who do not
smoke cigarette they still have COPD and
in those case the people have exposure
to long-term exposure to air pollution
okay chemical fumes second and small
secondhand smoke is a big factor so
that's right so when it is diagnosed
with COPD what are the next steps first
step is to come see you guys but what
are the steps walk us through what
happens if someone thinks they have it
and it comes to you so when they come to
us by taking a history and examining the
patient then we do a test called a
spirometry test okay which is a simple
test in the office we can do it and we
can make a diagnose a COPD on the basis
as paramedic test results okay and you
have the COPD Clinic tell me more about
that so cop Clinic is located at 3131 La
Canada Street and Suite 140 okay so in
this COPD Clinic you know we have one
provider which is me then we have a
nurse manager who's a disease management
then we have two care managers one is
the care manager others became an
assistant we assume respect therapist
and one we have one medical assistant
too no I I you know I've heard
commercials for COPD if you suffer from
COPD I hear about it if someone has it I
mean it is treatable this is this is not
some kind of life sentence if someone
has it they should you know a come see
you to get diagnosed if they have it but
then it's it's this is treatable yeah it
does and that's why I say it's a
preventable and treatable disease yeah
so it's not it's not a life sentence on
this no no not life sentence I love it
thank you so much doctor for joining us
we appreciate it and for more
information visit
intermountainhealthcare.org dot org
forward slash Nevada Las Vegas uh Las
Vegas now we'll be right back